>> CHABOT: Check, check. Hello, everyone,
I'm Chris Chabot and we're here today for,
"What's the hubbub about the Google Buzz API's."
So if you're not here to learn about the Google
Buzz API's, you should probably in the wrong
room; if you are, it's going to be awesome.
So I'm Chris Chabot and you can find me in
Google Buzz that's buzz.google.com/chabotc
and I'm also @chabotc on Twitter. If you are
tweeting about the event, we have two hashtags
up that's the I/O 2010 and for this talk we're
using the hash Buzz API. Also we're using
wave, live waving which is completely awesome
in conferences and I think the previous session
covered Wave pretty well as well. So if you
want to see life notes, if you want to ask
questions or anything else, we invite you
to join this URL. And you can answer your
questions there and we'll get to it at the
end of the session. So I wanted to start with
a little story. Two years ago we had the first
Google I/O, and at our first Google I/O, we're
also just start a talking about open social
and we told people the web is better when
it's social. And back in the date two years
ago, social was still relatively new concept
and we started sessions asking people to raise
their hand, who had the social profile or
not. Nowadays, you can't even imagine that
anymore because the web has already become
so social that having a social profile on
some kind of a social site this is common
as having a mobile phone. And I think we send
you a mobile phone so a few are pretty secure
saying that. The point though is that the
web is becoming a social place. We're moving
from a web that used to be about static information
where you have documents and big blobs of
text to a web that is about people connecting
with your friend, sharing experiences, playing
together, doing projects together, and talking
together. And as this phenomenon is growing
and growing, we are running into a few interesting
challenges, the challenges are that the web
is really a big place. There's all this different
destinations that you can go to but every
destination talks a different language, a
different culture, it can talk a different
protocol, it can have different terms of service,
it can have different contractual things that
you need to fill in before you can do business
with them. That's a potential issue because
your customers might be in the one of those
locations where you don't speak the language
or you don't understand the protocol. So we'd
like to solve that problem here at Google.
We believe that anything that is good for
the web is good for Google in the end so we
want the entire web to be very successful;
it is in our interest as well. So when we
were working in Google Buzz we first had done
it, we said we think it's very important that
we're going to build a platform that uses
all these open protocols that we do our biz
to help push the standards forward and help
develop the web in such a way that you can
be social anywhere in the web, that you can
join the conversation anywhere in the web,
that you can talk to people, connect to people,
play with people, share with people and everywhere.
It should be part of the infrastructure of
the web; it shouldn't be a special destination.
So when we build Google Buzz, we looked at
a lot of open protocols and one of them is
OAuth. OAuth is an old protocol that's been
around for a while and it's the effect of
protocol that people use for authenticating
themselves against the servers proving that
they have access to something. We also had
Atom, an Atom POP which has been around for
a long time since the beginning of the blogging
days and it defines a rich format for exchanging
information with each other and there's a
lots of libraries out there all ready that
are able to reached streams in certain formats.
And there's a lot of people have experienced
programming Atom POP using REST APIs and it's
a formative words really well on the Web,
so there was a logical choice for us to make.
The other thing is the RSS and RSS media which
define how pictures and other media can be
attached within a stream. Some cases, protocols
weren't fully developed yet and we spend a
lot of time on creating them. For instance,
Pubsubhubbub is one of the protocols that
makes it real time. You don't want to go to
a service and say are there any updates available
for me? Are there any updates available? If
you keep doing that all the time, it's not
going to be a real time, it's going to be
difficult to program and it's not going to
be very efficient either so. Push as we quote
in short makes it possible for content to
be pushed to you in real time. Activity Stream
was the format that we used to describe the
content that you'd be downloading when you're
talking to the service and Activity Stream
has a lot of rich information to Atom that
tells people what is happening, where it's
happening, et cetera. And, finally, we needed
something which isn't currently endorsed yet
but will be very soon and that's Salmon. The
problem space is that you're creating a message
on a different platform and you want to, that
match is to be pushed back into Buzz again.
So you need a way for confrontations to be
able to flow back upstream. And there's going
to be a session later today by John Panzer
and Joseph Smarr, "Bridging the Islands" and
they're going to go into deep, they're going
to do a deep dive into the technical details
about Salmon. So when we launched Buzz about
I think 99 days ago, that's about right. We
launched with two interfaces and we're quite
proud of them. We believe that the Gmail integration
worked really well. We're using it extensively
inside of Google as well and I think most
of our ideas and concepts are now brainstormed
about, within Google Buzz and our Gmail interface,
and we have a mobile version which is really
interesting because you can do location types
of services on that as well. But we don't
think that's enough. We want Buzz to be part
of a much bigger ecosystem. So, as of today,
we're launching the Buzz APIs that allows
you to do everything that you see in the interface
here. So you can do things like creating comments,
pushing comments into people's Buzz streams.
You can readout comments, either a consumption
stream as we call to people you follow or
your own stream. You can have rich media to
it like geolocations. You can do things like
commenting, liking, deleting, muting frets
and that all the operations that are connected
to a Buzz post, and you can attach pictures
and other rich media and you can work with
comments. We're also very happy to announce
a couple of partners have been helping us
to test the Buzz APIs we've been developing
as over the last two months and these are
the companies that will be launching some
form of Buzz support today. So there's going
to be a blogpost going out pretty soon that
will have links to their applications. And
actually two of those partners are, have been
kind enough to come on stage here later in
the session and talk about their experience
implementing the Buzz API. Before I gets started
on how all of this works, I want to give you
a bit of a warning that we do call this a
lab feature at the moment and that means that
we think that it's pretty much stable and
done, but we also know there are few things
still need to be developed. There's a lot
of open protocols where we still talking to
the community about what exactly the specification
should look like. We think that's okay, we
like iterating in the open where everybody
can weigh in with their opinions and experiences.
But that does mean that as these protocols
progressed and are developed, we might have
to change our API in a few minor ways. So
keep that in mind as you're developing that
there's going to be a few small changes down
the road. So with that out of the way, I wanted
to start on how does API works. First of all,
when you need to authenticate using OAuth
as I mentioned before, there's one thing slightly
different if you look at to normal Google
OAuth for Web applications, webpage. You'll
see lots of cool instructions there for how
to create your OAuth key and secret for your
own Web application? However, when you're
using Buzz, the authentication URL where you
redirect, the user needs to be a little bit
different and we've got it listed here. You
also need a few additional parameters in there.
You need to scope a domain and an iconURL
if you want to show your own logo. So if you
use that your authentication URL would look
a little bit like this, it should be encoded,
of course, so keep that in mind. Once you
do that you'll be redirected to a screen which
is modified from Google Buzz and it tells
end users a little bit more about what they
are allowing an application to do. So you
can see post, you can post stuff to your Buzz
stream, the application you can download information
about the people that you are connected to
pictures, fun mails, et cetera. At the moment,
you'll also notice that we have two [INDISTINCT]
screens that's a bit of a complicated issue.
It has a lot to do with how our internal systems
work. We know that this is far from an ideal
experience and it is going to be changed somewhere
in the future. After you've authenticated
and you have to fill OAuth talking setup,
you can talk to this REST API endpoint. As
I said it Atom POP based so that means that
for every action that you do with the Buzz
API and you're using URLs to talk to it. For
instance, if you want to create an activity,
you would use this URL/activities. We have
the documentation up for all the different
endpoints that you can talk to at this URL.
So that's code.google.com/apis/buzz/docs and
we've got very extensive big documentation
on every bit of the endpoints. I'm not going
to do too much of deep dive because I think
we got difference, 60 different mutations
that you can do there and that will take a
lot longer than this session is going to last.
We also have a couple of very useful tools
that are going to make it a lot easier to
play around for the Buzz API. The first thing
is something that's, the engineering team
while developing the API came up with, they
really liked curl, and they saw that Twitter
released of modified version of curl that
could talk to their API as well. We can do
better than that. We can make a curl version
that works with any OAuth and able endpoint.
So at this location, you could find a project
that they hacked up. It allows you to do a
curl operation to any OAuth enabled endpoint,
and it also has a couple of Buzz specific
hacks building so you can do an OA curl minus
Buzz login and it will log in to the Buzz
services right away for you. So using these
two, you can go to the command line and use
the rest already APIs already, if you want
to get serious about it. We also have started
developing a couple of client libraries which
are going to make your life a lot easier if
you're trying to build a web application.
And the PHP Client library is about 95% finished,
the Python library about 90%, the Java library,
the same. They are open source on our Apache
License, so if there's any functionality missing
or if you'd like to add anything to it, Apaches
are completely welcome and you can find the
issue tracker and the source repository on
these URLs. There's a few things that I wanted
to get out of the way as well about how does
REST API works? So first of all, you build
up a URL for the endpoint you want to talk
to, so we used buzz/v1 people to use the people
interface activities for the activities interface.
But there's a couple of query parameters that
all of these endpoints have in common. The
first is there's an alt, there's an alternative
output format. You can choose as a developer,
you prefer to use Atom or JSON based out per
format. In our experience, 90% of the developers
tend to like JSON, on the other hand the default
at the moment is Atom because there's a lot
of legacy readers out there that are Atom
enabled, and the great thing about activity
streams is that you can load up the URL for
your feed in any RSS or Atom reader and it
would still work out of the bug, so that's
the reason why we're using Atom as a default
output format. The other thing, if you're
developing especially if you're doing some
stuff from the command line, you'd probably
like the pretty print format because usually
we remove all the wide space, carriage returns,
et cetera, which makes things pretty unreadable
if you're trying to see what the output is.
So by putting in to pretty print, you'll get
a nicely formatted document back. The other
thing that we have on all rights operations
is a preview mode. If you're trying to create
a Buzz post and you want to show a preview
to the end user, how this Buzz post is going
to look like. For instance, you've attached
pictures to it, there's a link attachment,
videos, et cetera. You can do a post to the
endpoint for creating it and at preview equals
true and you will get back the representation
of what that object will look like and you
can display it in your own user interface.
So it's a great feature of letting users test
out what their actions are going to look like.
And the other things when you're reading out
a long list of return formats like if you're
getting a list of all the people you're connected
to, if you're getting a list of all the Buzz
post, you can use the max results, max likes,
the max comments to determine how many results
you want to get back. And there's also a continuation
to [INDISTINCT], if you're showing the first
20 results, you want to be able to page it
to the next 20 as well. Finally, everything
is also geo enabled both in what you will
get from the streams and what you can put
into it. So there's search queries, there's
a couple of things you can add to it. You
can add latitude and the longitude and a radius.
It allows you to search on some place on there,
or you can do bounding box. For instance,
if you're developing a mobile application
or using Google Maps to show all the different
post that are happening in some area. You
can use a square [INDISTINCT] called bounding
box for all, to get all the results in that
common area. Finally, I mentioned activity
streams in the introduction already. Activity
streams define a couple of useful bits of
information that you need when you're rendering
an output. The first is ruled that is action,
that's very important in social environment.
The other thing you need to know is what do
they do? So for instance, in this case they
were, I guess they're playing in this case.
It could also be martial arts practice but--so,
activity needs to have a person that's doing
something. It needs to have an action that's
being taken and it needs to know when that
action occurred. Finally that could be a few
extra bits of information on there. The contacts
in which the activity happened, and that could
be a location, the geolocation I mentioned
before, or it could be a mood or any other
kind of fields in there. I see we have some
cat fans in the audience that's good. So using
the command line tool, we can actually start
talking to this interface. So if you type
OAuth, OA curl fetch and then use the activities,
me, self, so that's going to give me my own
personal stream. You would execute as [INDISTINCT]
or you will get back a very long document
with lots of information in there. This is
more information that I may be able to fit
on the slide, so I chose to highlight a few
sections of it. First of all, in the root
element of the stream, you'll find a few useful
things that you need to render the context
around it. You'll find a title, you'll find
a date to which this stuff happened and there's
a unique ID. This ID, you will need future
operations if you want to do at the least
adding a common liking, muting, et cetera,
then this is the ID that you would use on
those operations. Secondly, as you can see
we have links element with a number of entries
in there, the likes, the self and replies
and they contained information about the stream
that you currently looking at, at this specific
entity in it. In this case, it would have
a URL where you can get all the people who
would like the post that you're looking at.
It would have accounts on there which is quite
useful if it has a count zero, you know you
don't have to render anything, and you don't
have to make any API calls to retrieve any
information. Otherwise, you can either choose
to have lots of likes already included in
the mainstream, or if you specify the max
liked equal to some number, you can tell the
Buzz API output to include those in the mainstream
itself. So it depends on the type of application
design you're doing, if you have more of an
AJAX, C or a mobile phone type small interface
where you're not sure in your comment. You
want to use this counter and say, click here
to show all the comments on this item. If
on the other hand, you're building a big Web
application where you want to show the fully
rendered stream, you want to say, max liked
equals some high number so can have everything
back in one single request. The same goes
for replies. You can either look at the counter
here and say, click here to download all the
replies or you can choose to include a max
replies equals some number to have them included
in base stream as well. Another important
part on activity streams, we already had one
that happened in ID is who did this? We called
that the actor within the activity. So you
got a basic information set all the name and
ID, a profile URL if you want to create a
link where you can link to the profile page
and a thumbnailURL where you can get a visual
picture of Avatar, the icon for this person.
The third part of an activity is the verb,
what happens in this activity? The activity
stream supports lots of different verbs. At
the moment the only thing you should expect
from Buzz is a post verb. Somebody created
a Buzz post; in the future this might expand
though. And finally, in the user interface
in Gmail home mobile we're showing a source,
where did this activity occur? So we're including
that in the stream as well and you have a
textual stream there and that could be anything.
In this case, the stuff was created in the
Buzz interface. It could be a website address,
it could be the domain name you're using,
it could be from the Web, and it could be
an ominous, so this is free textual string,
don't build any code that depends on this
having a certain value. It's more that if
you want to show exactly the same thing as
you're showing in the Gmail front end, then
this is the string you want to include in
there where it says, "Chrishabel posted a
Buzz from," in this case "Google Buzz." And
there's visibility included. Google Buzz is
a unique product where you can use the group
selector to choose if you want to have your
post being completely public or you only wanted
to go to a certain set of people, a private
post. So the visibility defines which groups
have access to this Buzz. If it's public that
means that everybody has access to it. If
there's a different URL here with a different
name then that means that a person submitted
a Buzz post with a surrogate targeting. Who
can actually read this Buzz post? The one
thing to keep in mind and this is still someone
in flux; we weren't sure what to do with private
postings especially since not every interface
at the moment has a great UI for showing which
post are private and which post are public
and we don't want to accidentally start exposing
private information. So we made the choice
that at launch we're not returning private
post except if you've created them yourself.
And the other situation, you got an empty
document with a bit of basic information of
a date and an actor, there's not going to
be any content in there. So if you're writing
code and you happen to stumble across an empty
activity that's the reason why there's probably
some private group visibility selected there.
Also, if a Buzz post contains geolocation
that's going to be included in it. It can
be either a geocode and an address, it could
only be a geocode or it could even have a
place name in there if it's a recognized location
within our systems. And finally the last bit
of an activity string there needs to be an
object. Something happened to some things
that's the object of activity. And currently
Google Buzz will only create notes and note
is pretty much a bit of text. Again, in the
future, as we're expanding the system and
we're iterating out in the open developing
these standards and developing what we need
to support will probably have more object
types. But, for the time being, the notes
are all good that you can have to expect.
However, if an object is more complicated
than just a bit of text strings as if somebody
posted a link, then you need to have attachments.
You're going to have an object and there's
going to be an attachment connected to it.
The attachments can have many different formats.
In this example we're using a link, so there's
going to be an article which is what a link
attached to an object is called. In activity
streams, there's going to be a name there,
that's the name that you want to put on the
screen and you're going to have to add a value
attach to it. But maybe you were also uploading
a picture. So you're going to get a different
attachment type that includes an image, a
photo. And the same happened for a video and
that depends on the type of attachment what
information is going to be connected to it.
So for an image, you're going to have a width
and a height; for a video, you're going to
have multiple locations that you can link
to that either have a video URL or the containing
page, et cetera. And these are all the verbs
that you could expect to see happening in
the future. As I said at the moment we're
only supporting a subset of these, but as
we're importing more resources into Google
Buzz and that's we're expanding the user interfaces
and iterating on what we think would be valuable
to have in the interface; more of these should
be popping up. So when you're developing your
code, make sure to keep that in mind that
you're riding a big switch case, a statement,
or riding lots of ifs and not hard coning
any assumptions on what your input is going
to be. Because it is a REST API that means
you can also do interesting things for the
same locations. For instance, if you have
your own activities you could do a post to
it and in a RESTful API doing a post to URL
means you're creating a post. A RESTful API
also means that whatever you read out of it
you can push back into it. So if we're looking
at the same object as we are reading out of
it on activity objects, you could push exactly
the same JSON blob back into it with a post
and that will create actual Buzz post for
you. Likewise, if you want to like something,
you go the likes URL with the comment's ID
that you want to like and you do a post operation.
And if you want to unlike something you will
do a delete operation on a sim. There's also
a lot of libraries that we're busy developing.
I develop the PHP once, I'm going to use that
as an example. Well, we also have the Python
one that works and App Engine and the stand
alone modem, we have the Java one, and they
all have a lot of examples building. So they
have examples on how you can download a stream
both the public one as well as your private
one. How to add a post, how to like stuff,
mutes stuff, delete stuff, there's too many
examples really to mention here, so I'm literally
not going to try. But the cool thing is they're
all open sourced. There's a lot of implementations
out there where you can just cut and paste
bits of operation that you want to do. And
there's examples of how to do high fidelity
rendering of a Buzz string for instance. And
you can actually, if you want to, you can
start checking out a few of these demos if
you go www.buzz-demos.com, and I'm hosting
a live version of the PHP demos up there.
The way it works and this is pretty much the
same for all of the libraries is that you
create the global Buzz objects. You do some
OAuth magic that's thankfully taking care
off for you. And you got an object back that
you can start doing operations on. For instance,
you could get all the consumptions you impose,
which means the people that you're following.
You see there's a number of numbers added
to it which is the maximum number of post.
The likes and replies that you want to get.
So, from that, you get an object back that
contains the entire stream of your consumption
post. You want to start iterating through
it and for instance you want to see, "Hey,
I've got a link. I've got a type of objects
at the moment it's only a note. It could be
more in the future." We've got attachments
connected to it. There's a lot of different
types that we're supporting right now; photos,
photo albums, attachments, videos, articles;
you want to create some custom layout here.
The nice thing about us using activity streams
is that you got the rich information about
an activity. So, you know the URL, you know
where the video is, you know how to do rich
rendering. You don't have to just take a blob
of HTML and put it in your own page and hoped
that somehow magically did layouts kind of
works in your own site. Now because you have
to made an information you can be creating
your own layout around these objects. And,
finally, you want to display this content
that you've created. Likewise, if you want
to create a Buzz post, you would create an
attachment because we want to put a link in
there. You give it a URL that you want to
link to, you give it a title and you create
the post objects. Then you just do a Buzz
create post and it will be pushed to the server
and there's going to be an exception if there
was an error if it returns new objects. You
can display that as this was the result of
your action. So using these libraries really
simplifies talking to the API quite a bit.
You can start hooking a Buzz support by the
pushing content to it or reading content from
Buzz in a couple of line of code. There's
a lot of features that we're still working
on implementing at the moment. For instance,
one of the things that we're working on and
it might be working today, so this is kind
of exciting is full push support for Buzz.
I know that for non-authenticated streams
to support should be in there today. I'm looking
at the audience here. Sammy, do you know push
support? Yes, I'm getting a yes, okay. So
with a bit of luck at 3 p.m., there's going
to be a session by John Panzer and Joseph
Smarr, "Bridging the Islands." And he's going
to be doing a live demo of this stuff in action.
Forcedly, when I was finishing my slides yesterday
it wasn't a 100% sure yet, so I'm not going
to be able to go and to do too much detail
myself. We're also still figuring out how
to reach your support, more inputs. We're
working with standard committee so, there's
going to be a lot interesting stuff happening
around the API. We've got a lot of interesting
concepts as well and I'm seeing some really
inspired faces here ready to start programming
on them as soon as they've slept for a weekend.
So, watching the space, there's going to be
a lot of cool stuff added to it. And with
that, I wanted to give the stage to Marco,
Seesmic, who've been working and implementing
support in their products.
>> KAISER: Yes, the microphone is on. Thank
you, Chris, and also for the opportunity to
present us here in this session at Google
I/O 2010. My name is Marco, I work for Seesmic
and I'm the Director of Engineering and desktop
client lead there. And I want to talk about
integrating Buzz into our applications today.
First, a little bit about Seesmic, if you
haven't heard about us yet. We want to try
to solve a simple problem which is if you
want to share with all your friends and get
the feedback and comments from all your friends
you have to visit a lot of different networks
today. And what we try to do is bring that
all together and deliver the real time Web
to you wherever you are, whatever platform
you're on, and whichever device you're using.
So we want to provide one unique solution
which you can use across all the platforms.
When Google asked us if we wanted to take
part in the launch of the Buzz API, we're
really excited because that is like a perfect
match for us. And when we looked at the API,
we found out that they were as, Chris already
said, completely relying on open standards.
So we have OAuth, we have part of a contacts
with Atom, JSON, RESTful APIs, Activity Streams.
Our teams already have a lot of experience
with these technologies and there's a lot
of information out there on the Web and there's
code that we could reuse. So, even if that
just like having a couple of weeks ago and
we could start like really late on doing that.
With all that information and all that experience
that was already there, it was pretty easy
for us to get up the speed fast and implement
that. And, of course, another advantage of
using open technology is there's no licensing
issues that we had to deal with, it's all
open. It's pretty good on the legal side so
we shouldn't have like big issues there, so
it's really good, it helped us a lot to get
up the speed and implement this fast. So,
as our vision, as Seesmic gets to support
as many services as possible and to support
as many platforms if possible, I'm really
happy to say that we can add Buzz now to our
desktop products, to our Android product and
also to our Web product. Let me start with
desktop first. About two months ago we first
showed our next generation of our desktop
client, Seesmic Desktop which is a very popular
social networking application. It's build
on the Silverlight platform as out of browser
application, so it's running on Windows and
it's running on Mac with the same code. And,
but it's not just a client, it's a platform
itself. So we were, based on that platform
able to create a plugin platform and implement
all the features that we have in the client
ourselves as plugins already. So Twitter,
Facebook, even the Buzz integration now, that's
all a plugin on that platform and it's open
to third party developer so everyone can extend
the functionality of the implication with
your own plugins if you want to. We've published
the preview of the SDK already for that. So
as we have network here hopefully we should
be able to give you a quick demo on that.
So here we have the application running, this
is the Seesmic Desktop 2 preview, which is
running with the Buzz account here. If I go
to the settings in the application and go
to the plugins here, I can see that everything
here is really implemented as a plugin. So
we have a Bing Maps plugin here--oh, I shouldn't
have said that on the Google conference but
we do. But you can see that's Google Buzz,
there's Facebook in here, Foursquare, LinkedIn,
Twitter; everything, all of that is a plug
in and we can just drop it in or remove it
and the client will either like be extended
by the functionality or it will be removed.
So for the best support, like all other services
we have, like Twitter, Facebook, you get timelines
of your Buzz feeds. So, for example, here
is a timeline, in that timeline you can see
images that were attached to posts. If there
are comments you can click here and you get
the list of comments from people. People liked
it, so there are already a couple of people
who like that post and you can see that at
the bottom. But, of course, you can also update
your Buzz status from here, so I can just
go in here. I have my accounts selected here,
right now, postings only supported as public.
So we're looking forward to add the privacy
controls there as soon as we can over the
API. But I can just like post something here
and hopefully the network works for that and
just add a new post which, like it shows at
the top. Hello, from [INDISTINCT] like, you
can just like do everything I want, obviously,
it also have the ability to search from the
application here if I want to, so I can do
a search for Buzz here. We should get results
for Buzz from Google Buzz. Yeah, that's the
demo for that. So, if you're interested about
that, and most especially the plugin platform,
if you're interested to start developing,
I said Buzz is a plugin itself. If you have
something that you want to develop with the
client, platform.seesmic.com, is the location
to go and to learn more about the platform
there. I said desktop was the first platform,
Web is the second platform. We also have a
very successful Web based client, which is
the lightweight and easy to use. You don't
have to install anything on your computer
and, of course, we also have to add Buzz there.
Let me just jump into that one if I have right
window here. So here you see a preview of,
well, not a preview anymore but, you'll see,
oh, excuse me, Web client running with Buzz.
This is to a Twitter list we just opened here.
But I can click on Google Buzz in the sidebar
and I get the same timeline which I just had
in my desktop client and it's all in here
too. I have the same features in here by commenting.
I can obviously also post from here, post
a comment--oops, sorry that was the mouse.
And it post the comment on, I can update my
status from here so I can also select which
accounts I want to use, in that case I have
a Tweeter account and a Buzz account here
so I can cross post to both services. I can
just select one whatever I want. So this is
from Seesmic Web. And I'll update my status
from here, so that's about Web which I just
demoed. Third, for us, which is very important
is our Android based client. All mobile spaces
are growing like crazy and also thanks to
the success of the Android platform. And Seesmic
has a very popular social mini-Twitter right
now application in the marketplace already
which has been downloaded more than 250,000
times already. And I mean Android, Google
Buzz, that's just a perfect match so there
was no question for us that we have to add
Google Buzz also to the Android application.
So what you can see here on the screens on
the left-hand side, I can't demo it on stage
there's no cameras so, I have to fall back
to a screenshots here. Is the timeline of
a Google Buzz account within the application?
You can see this is the following timelines.
You also see the tabs at the top so you also
have a nearby so that's the bounding box that
we talked about. You can restrict the two
locations. You can search, you can view your
profile, you can cross post to Twitter accounts
and Buzz accounts. You can limit to either
or whatever you want any combination there
is possible. If you go to a detailed view
of a message and you see the message but you
also have actions like delete in this case,
it's the author's own account, so he can delete
his own message. There's the like button,
there's the comment button where you can see
the list of comments as you see on the right,
and there's a commenting box at the bottom
which you can use so it's, all that functionality
is there. The last but not least, Seesmic
also owns Ping.fm which is a service that
allows you to update dozens of services at
once and of course updating the status is
very important and Buzz, that's the core feature
of Buzz so, that has to be in our support
too. So,
we can also add your Buzz account to Ping.fm
and update your status to all networks including
Buzz now. So when is this going to be available?
Well, today. Seesmic Web and Ping.fm are releasing
the support for Buzz as of today and maybe
it's already live. I'm looking at--Yuhan,
yes; he says yes. So, both services are live
now with Buzz support. Seesmic Desktop 2 was
introduced as a previous, so we're not like
calling it really like finished product. But
for the first time today we're making it available
for end users to download from our website--sorry,
so, seesmic.com/sd2. We'll get you installer
for the application which includes the Buzz
plugin of course and platform that Seesmic
that I've said for plugin for developers.
And for Seesmic, for Android, if you want
to see a preview of the application, you should
visit us down at the Sandbox booth and we
can give you a link to download and install
the application, it's not in the marketplace
yet but, it would be there soon. Yeah, so,
thanks. If you want to learn more about Seesmic,
please come to www.seesmic.com and with that
back to Chris.
>> CHABOT: Oh, thank you, Marco, and these
guys really have been working day and night
to get this demo done today and actually going
live so, we very much appreciate all your
efforts, guys. And the next stop we have Socialwok
talking about their experience integrating
Google Buzz. So, I'd like to introduce Ming
who will be doing the demo.
>> YONG: So, hi, guys. I'm Ming Yong from
Socialwok. So for those wo are not familiar
with Socialwok, right, socialwok.com, you
can see--some people have got Facebook for
business on Google Apps. We basically create
a collaborated work space for your Google
Apps domain. So you can also use your Gmail
account or your Google Apps account or any
work email account, and actually just sign
on and you can create and you can see it's
a feed-based format like this where you can,
and you're commenting and you can share which
media we actually share files in Google Docs,
Google Calendar, the whole works. All right.
Now, let's go--so what I want to do today
is I'm going to start off a demo to show you
how we have integrated with Google Buzz. Now,
so, you can see here Navin Kumar, Navin is
my CTO and co-founder of Socialwok. He has
a Google profile as you can see there, right?
And you can see all the updates. So, what
we're going to do first is we're going to
setup Socialwok to pull in your Google Buzz
or any Google Buzz profile you like. So, we
go to the Socialwok and then settings, and
you can see we support actually [INDISTINCT]
services. We support Twitter, pulling from
Twitter, Facebook, LinkedIn and now we're
going to do Buzz, so first thing which was
setup to actually pull in the connected sites
for Google Buzz--so, Navin for the connected
sites. So, what is Navin going to do now?
He's going to enter his, basically, his Google
Buzz username, and even notice, all we have
to do is just put SWok task 1, right? We actually
use WebFinger which is supported under the
Google Buzz if you stack to actually get the
endpoint. So once safe, we automatically recognize
this, actually Navin Kumar Google profile.
So this is very nice for developers to actually
just easily get a person's Google profile,
just using WebFinger. And what we're going
to do is authenticate. Here, this is OAuth,
authentication with Google Buzz and you can
see a very nice page, right, that shows you
that Chris actually just showed just now,
of all the access that you're getting with
Google Buzz. So this is for us to post out
from Socialwok to Google Buzz, and you can
choose multiple accounts. So once authentication
is granted, what we're going to do is we're
going to post in Google Buzz, and Socialwok
and then you'll go out to Google Buzz. Here,
Navin is going to type a message that we're
demoing at Google I/O and he will put web
link. So something to know about Socialwok
is that, as you can see, as I mentioned, we
actually showing various things like Google
Docs, so you can actually just insert on the,
any of the smaller tabs, so we also preview
your website. So you can see, right, once
he typed the web link, it actually has the
images of the actual website so you can attach.
It is a new way to do sharing. The interesting
thing that I wanted you to know is CC, so
you actually type CC in Google Buzz. So once
the checkbook has been done and you click
share it would actually publish simultaneously
to Socialwok, to your private web group of
colleagues as well as out to Google Buzz,
so this is called the public Buzz. So you
can see here in Buzz, right there, we have
successfully published. Going back to Socialwok
and you can see, yeah, the things there. Now
the next thing we're going to show is, Gmail.
Socio-integrate very tightly with email, we
can forward email into a feed. We can also
now support--Google has recently launch Gmail
contextual gadget technology. Now, in Socialwok,
we have this Socialwok, social gadgets, so
we can see here, do you see at the bottom
of the email, there's three profiles, right?
So let me explain, so this mail is coming
from mgyong@gmail.com to navine@socialwok
and veecrom@socialwok.com. So Veecrom and
Navin are both co-workers in Socialwok. So,
you can see in the Gmail contextual gadget,
they'll show status, updates, the activity.
So while reading a mail you can now get the
social activity of your colleague's, right
there. You can see the status, you can see
the emails that has been shared and the files.
So Navin maybe you can quit--the yeah. Now,
you can click on Ming, so this is me. This
person right is mgyong@gmail.com. He is not
a member of Socialwok yet that's why you don't
see the status update. But in Socialwok, we
have the ability to actually do mail threading.
So you can see the quick mail, these are all
the mails that are shared between mgyong@gmail.com
and the Socialwok guy. Now, this is the Buzz.
You can see here we actually support pulling
in of the Google Buzz updates. So now, as
developers, you can actually start bringing
social context into your applications as we
have demonstrated, and we can just actually
invite. If you want to invite the person that
collaborate with you on Socialwok, you can
just type in the email address, the custom
message and instantly you bring that sharing
and collaboration right into Gmail, into your
Google Apps as well as with Google Buzz. Yeah,
now, let me just quickly--I'll take the next
few minutes to actually talk a little bit
more on the developer, how a developer would
lavish on our experience with Google Buzz.
So before we actually got access to the Buzz
APIs, we started work on this about three,
four months ago. We were actually, we decided,
we took a stand that we wanted to support
open social web, right? We want to support
open standards. So things we supported was
Pubsubhubbub. To pull, as we have demonstrated,
just to pull in feeds, we could now pull in
feeds from Facebook. We can pull in feeds
from Twitter, and now we can pull in Buzz
as well as any RSS and Atom feed. We also
supported Activity Streams, right, and including
the extensions like Media RSS for rich format
and GeoRSS for Geo location. As well as you
saw in the demonstration, right, WebFinger,
we can just get access to one, the Gmail,
use a part and we automatically get access
to the URL. And lastly, we use OAuth to authenticate
with Google Buzz as well as all the other
services like Twitter and Facebook. So in
terms of Google Buzz specifically, right,
we actually, in the demo, in the demonstration
we actually show 3-legged OAuth. So this 3-legged
OAuth is an extension of what we do commonly
with Twitter and LinkedIn. And the other thing
that we demonstrated was the CC-ing and posting
to Buzz. So we actually post to and uses direct
endpoint, the feed endpoint. Lastly, we actually
put in the Google profile into a Gmail contextual
gadget, right. So we just get the Gmail address,
we post to user part and we use part of the
context to discover, to do discovery of the
guy's profile and finally use the Buzz API
to actually fetch that update in. Next, so
as demonstrated just now, that was the Gmail
contextual, the Socialwok social gadget, right.
Now, you can actually get social context right
in email. So what are the cool things that
we found about the Buzz APIs? It struck as
that, guess what? When we support others open
standards like Pubsubhubbub and Activity Streams,
Portable Contacts, it took almost zero work
for us to actually integrate with Google Buzz
which was very amazing because most other
services take a long work. So we, because
Google Buzz actually supported open social
type of URL, so we were able to just post
directly like all the updates we have, all
Activity Streams generated. We just took the
same Activity Stream format and literally
just post it to Buzz and with zero modification
it just got published. And the other very
cool thing that we supported by Google Buzz
was this thing called crosspost namespace.
So as you know, right, we have a status update
that's published in Socialwok and the same
update is actually published out to Google
Buzz. Now, what we can do is that in the process
of publishing out, we can invent the ID of
the Socialwok post inside that Google Buzz.
So you can do very interesting things like
refer to the original post and you can do
things like file sharing. In Socialwok, as
you can see, we attached files, right, in
Google Docs in the update. We could publish,
say, hey, I'm sharing this file with you guys
on Google Buzz and in that URL you can click
that link and it will reference back the message
in Socialwok. And when they click and it goes
back, they have to authenticate to get access
to the files. So, interesting scenarios like
that could be leveraged by developers. Now,
in terms of future work for Socialwok with
Google Buzz, as you've seen we support file
attachments, Google Docs, Google Calendar,
the whole works. We share everything Google
in Socialwok. So this rich media can now be
shared using Buzz attachments. So this is
the next thing will be supporting. The second
thing is you also saw, right, Socialwok supports
commenting of updates. We could imagine federation
of these comments to other social networks
or from other social networks into Socialwok,
but that thing is Buzz results. So in Socialwok
right now--sorry, Buzz search. Right now,
in Socialwok, we support Twitter search. So,
literally, any users can just put a keyword
and it will pull in from Twitter constantly,
right, using or pulling. But you could imagine
now with Buzz search, we can actually do the
same thing and Pubsubhubbub, using Pubsubhubbub.
The fourth thing is private Buzz. Right now,
what we have demonstrated is all public and
Buzz is soon to be giving support of Google
Apps and you could imagine we can actually
post from Socialwok, to private Buzz using
authenticated OAuth. And lastly is context
integration. Socialwok supports Google context
already, right? In social right now you just,
you don't type any email address, we will
actually query your Google context directly.
With Google Buzz APIs we could foresee actually
getting access to the Google Buzz context
including the people you follow, other people
who are following you, and then use that in
Socialwok. So these are the things we have
done with Socialwok. And if you want to check
with Socialwok, just go on web@socialwok.com
and you can create your own social collaborated
network on Google Apps or any Gmail account.
And before I end, one thing to note, Seesmic
has launched the Seesmic Desktop 2 and Socialwok
now is also gone to the desktop. We are proud
to announce this morning our partnership with
Seesmic, that Socialwok is now on the desktop
using the Seesmic plugins. So, thank you,
everybody.
>> CHABOT: Awesome. Thanks, guys. Cool. So,
closing words, we have been able to show a
couple of functionalities that we currently
have built in to the Buzz APIs. We believed
we've given you the functionality to do everything
that you're seeing in the current interface.
We've shown a couple of examples of what you
could do with this APIs, you can build classic
messaging clients, you can integrate into
your enterprise applications and we'll be
having some sessions later today as well.
Where--tomorrow, actually, yeah, it's Thursday,
isn't it? Yeah, so Thursday there's going
to be another session about Buzz and it's
going to cover the concepts of how to use
these kinds of APIs in the Python environment
to build a game for instance. If you want
to learn more about the API, the Docs is a
great place to start. We have a mailing list
setup, they will be monitoring and answering
all your questions as well. So if you want
learn more, if you have any questions, if
there's any other burning stuff that we can
help with, you can find us there in the mailing
list. Do check out the OAuth enabled curl
if you want to play with the API from the
command line and we have to free libraries
enables for Buzz support. So, tomorrow, we
have to surf the stream session that would
be covering how to build a game using the
Buzz APIs, and using a Python environment
and also tomorrow, later in the day, we'll
have fireside chat with most of the PMs and
directors of the various social branches with
Google. So if you have any questions about
Google's future direction about social--what
decisions we make with Google Buzz, et cetera.
What we're planning to do in the future that
will be the place to ask the right people.
Finally, don't forget to check out the wave
that's where people will leaving comments,
asking questions, et cetera. And with that,
I'd like to move to questions and answers.
If you do have a question, I would like to
ask you to use the microphones please, otherwise,
the video won't be able to pick up on it.
>> Just a quick question, where do you have
ActionScript API support?
>> CHABOT: I didn't get that, I'm sorry.
>> ActionScript flanks and flash.
>> CHABOT: ActionScripts, no, we don't have
a library for that at moment. We do have someone
working in my team who was very excited about
building one. So my suggestion would be to
send out a mail to our mailing list saying,
hey, I'm really interested in the ActionScript
library, and he'll respond to that and you
can either help him out or make sure you can
update us when it's available.
>> Cool, I know yours, you will also need
to open up the policy for that.
>> CHABOT: Okay.
>> Okay, thanks.
>> CHABOT: Any other questions? Feel free.
Nothing at all? Okay, well, thank you very
much for coming guys. I hope you enjoyed the
presentation and if you have any other questions
you can find me in the hallways. Thanks.